[Musique]
au pied de la tour de la bourse de
toronto un petit kiosque à adobe
délaissé ndoulo de wisair banquiers et
investisseurs depuis plus de trente ans
il pensait avoir tout vu tout vécu
il perd de l'argent presque chaque jour
depuis le printemps
normalement trois millions de personnes
travaillent dans les tours du centre
ville de toronto
le coeur du secteur financier canadien
selon un sondage de la chambre de
commerce de la région entre 80 et 85%
des employés travaillent de la maison
depuis le début de la pandémie commerces
barricadés ventes de fermeture les
conséquences de l'exode des tours de
bureaux sont dramatiques pour les petits
commerçants du centre-ville de la plus
grande métropole du pays
les banquiers de bay street représenter
une part importante de la clientèle de
son magasin de chaussures de luxe
puisqu'ils sont en télétravail et ne
viennent plus dans son commerce
vishal hussein n'a plus les moyens de
payer son loyer de près de quatorze
mille dollars par mois
il ne restera plus que les grandes
entreprises et les chaînes de
restaurants ou de magasins prédit-il
ce sont les seuls qui en ont les moyens
dans les conditions actuelles
c'est la crainte de nombreux petits
commerçants
et si les employeurs des grandes tours
de bureaux réalisées qu'il est possible
d'être tout aussi productif à la maison
qu'au bureau et que les changements
imposés par la pandémie devenait
permanent c'est simple il sera
impossible de survivre au centre-ville
de toronto croit ce restaurateur qui a
besoin de la clientèle de bay street le
midi pour survivre si son restaurant
n'est pas plein à craquer en tout temps
il ne fait aucun profit il a peur rien
que de penser à l'avenir au centre-ville
le télétravail permanent pour des
centaines de milliers d'employés
pourraient libérer des étages entiers
des tours de bureaux du centre ville ce
qui représente une occasion d'affaires
inégalé selon la chambre de commerce de
la région de toronto
des entreprises de haute technologie
souhaitait d'ailleurs s'installer à
toronto avant la pandémie
le manque d espace commercial et est
devenu un obstacle important pour
attirer des capitaux étrangers
pour l'instant les grands employeurs
cherchent des façons de ramener les
travailleurs au bureau à court terme
mais certaines solutions pourrait aussi
s'avérer permanente système de
réservation des ascenseurs par exemple
pourrait prévenir les longues files
d'attentes et rendre les tours du centre
ville plus sécuritaire
[Musique]
un giuly lui n'a pas les moyens de
rester pour assister à la transformation
de son centre-ville et formica rabat
c'est une tragédie dit il ils voudraient
pouvoir pleurer mais il n'en a plus la
force il si philippe leblanc radio
canada toronto